la forme classique du film extraterrestre
dans l'ouest les rassemble et
crée quelque chose de nouveau et d'excitant en tant que
réalisateur cette image était très convaincante
ils donneraient une action vraiment cool
chaque jour que quelque chose se
passerait avec beaucoup d'explosions parce que nous
avions  pour combiner en quelque sorte la réalité avec les
effets que j'aime, il y a une progression dans
les séquences d'action la première fois que nous avons
rencontré les extraterrestres, il fait nuit
dans cette ville du vieil ouest, vous avez tous
nos personnages principaux ici, puis lentement
à l'horizon, les lumières viennent et puis
avant qu'ils ne sachent ce qu'ils font
exploser en train d'arracher des gens,
l'esprit du 18ème 19ème siècle n'a aucune idée de
ce qu'ils regardent et des revenus sur
ces câbles que nous avions installés à 60 70
miles à l'heure ces lumières géantes sur une
plate-forme de  l'équipe de la caméra araignée puis des
explosions avec ces faisceaux laser, nous mettons en
place des explosions pratiques
soufflant hors de cette ville parce que nous avons
pu la truquer pendant un certain temps
des choses qui étaient spécifiquement nerveuses
juste pour exploser, donc tout le monde s'est
réuni de manière pratique plutôt que de
s'appuyer sur l'infographie pour créer
cette première attaque de ville, c'était une
première aventure pour moi en termes de
certainement la plus grande cascade que j'ai faite
et nous obtenons  harnaché et cette chose
est une énorme grue parfois un gars
aimera littéralement sauter d'un bâtiment et
son poids vous tirera vers le haut vous savez 20
pieds dans les airs c'était fou je veux dire que je
courais autour d'une ville qui
explosait avec Harrison Ford et  tout d'
un coup, je me fais tirer dessus et je regarde
harrison alors que je me fais tirer dans les airs
dont
tu es sauvage